[Music]
there is nothing more american than
apple pie it is one of the most popular
and recognizable desserts in the world
hi my name is jordan i'm a producer here
at tasty and today we're going to do
something a little different recently
while thumbing through our new cookbook
i found this strange recipe for
something called a mock apple pie it
contains no apples and uses simple
crackers as a substitute which begs the
question how can something without
apples taste like apple pie so today i'm
going to make this recipe and feed it to
a few of my co-workers see if they can
spot the difference
[Music]
i'm going to start by sifting two cups
of flour with two teaspoons of sugar and
one teaspoon of salt then i'm going to
add 10 tablespoons of butter that have
cubes and chills i chilled the butter
beforehand because it's really important
to keep this cold the heat from my hands
should be enough to allow me to work the
butter into the flour i'm really just
kind of pressing my fingers working it
together until it forms a nice sandy
texture
i'm gonna add a third of a cup of cold
water as the water hydrates the flour
it'll develop a loose lumpy texture
that'll start to clump together on the
fork at this point i'll turn the dough
out and start to bring it together with
my hands
once it does come together into a nice
mound i'm going to cut it in half and
form each of the halves into nice round
half inch disks and i'm going to wrap
those in cling film and put them in the
fridge for an hour
while these pie crusts chill in the
fridge i'm going to move on to the
filling to start we're going to make a
simple syrup solution out of one and
three quarters cups of sugar with two
teaspoons of cream of tartar added to it
to that we're going to pour over one and
one-half cups of water once this mixture
has come to a boil and the sugar is
fully dissolved i'm going to reduce the
heat to low and let it simmer for about
15 minutes before taking it off the heat
now i'm going to add the only other
flavorings to the syrup
a half a teaspoon of cinnamon and the
zest and juice of one lemon
i know you can't smell this right now
but this combination of lemon juice
sugar and cinnamon smells exactly like
apple pie if the pie tastes like this
mixture smells we are going to trick a
lot of people so while that's happening
i'm going to preheat my oven and begin
to roll out my dough it's important to
rotate your dough as you roll it out
this will help you get a nice round
shape that will encompass the diameter
of whatever you're baking it in we're
going for a standard nine inch pie dish
so i want my dough to be at least an
inch or two larger than that on all
sides i'm going to use the rolling pin
to pick it back up and lay it over the
top next i'm going to gently use my
hands to press the dough into the bottom
of the pie dish
now we're on to the fun part the recipe
calls for 2 cups or about 4 ounces of
coarsely broken buttery crackers now in
order to make this work and deceive my
co-workers i think i need to keep these
in pretty large pieces if they're too
fine i'm afraid the syrup will turn them
into a thick paste that won't look
anything like an apple pie on the inside
once i've broken up all the crackers and
added them to the pie crust i'm going to
dot the top with another two tablespoons
of cubed butter as you would any normal
apple pie once i have my top crust on
i'm going to take that little bit of
overhang and tuck it under itself while
pressing it against the lip of the pie
dish next i'll use a fork to crimp the
edge of the dough all the way around
as a finishing touch before putting the
pie in the oven i'm going to give it a
light egg wash by beating one egg with
one tablespoon of water and brushing it
across the surface
and finally to make sure the pie doesn't
explode in the oven i'm going to cut a
small vent in the center to let the
steam escape
after 35 minutes i was left with this
from here i can tell you it smells like
an apple pie it looks like an apple pie
i am really excited to see what my
co-workers think when they have a slice
of this
okay so
loving this crust loving the you know
clean cut visually
it's on the mark and this looks fresh
and definitely homemade um you can see
the layers of apple they're like thinly
sliced which is great can i smell it
first
very suspicious
[Music]
i like it
i like that it's not as like there
aren't like obvious chunks of apple in
it because that always grosses me out
okay yeah it's sweet like you want it
the apples are like um perfectly
mushy cheers
you know i like this there's like
definitely you can taste the cinnamon
and the i don't know but
there's like other elements of it that
i'm not used to in apple pie it's good
the flavors are there but i would guess
like you use applesauce or something
like some kind of a
different apple would be my guest hold
on let me
what
oh my no wonder i actually like this one
oh my goodness now i can kind of see
that that's crazy
because the flavor is there so there's
no apples in this
so wait hold on okay
okay hold on so there's no apples but it
tastes a little bit like apples
these are crackers
i'm sorry so we're not eating we're not
eating apple pie i actually like this
way better than normal apple pie but the
one thing that now i realize is you can
see the little like ridges of the
crackers
i have a really good childhood friend
who's allergic to apples and can eat any
apple stuff i would like get this
cookbook to give to her and be like
here's your taste
of america
i think it compares to apple pie like
it's a pretty good replica and i'm not
gonna lie the worst part about preparing
a fruit pie like apple pie is when you
have to get like your mandolin or your
like slicer and start like peeling these
apples and coring them and chopping them
up so this is like a much easier way to
pull off an apple pie i feel like i
should be like oh weird but like i want
to keep eating it i mean it looked like
a pie smelled like pie tastes like a pie
i'm here for it i've been bamboozled but
i'm gonna eat it
how dare you
i will go on record and say that i
thought this was apples
but
if it's good it's good and if it's
delicious it's delicious and it was so
i i don't mind being being deceived i'm
done for this pie i'm i'm for it i'm
team mac if this is what the mock apple
pie tastes like i can't wait to try the
actual apple pie in the cookbook and so
now i'm super curious
this mock apple pie was a huge hit and a
really fun experiment nearly everyone
was fooled
if you want to try this recipe for
yourself make sure to check out our
newest cookbook tasty ultimate it
features dozens of never before seen
recipes tips tricks and recipe showdown
just like this one get your copy today
by clicking the link below
[Music]
you